[Musique]
je profite de ses derniers instants du
jeudi avec monsieur bonne amie dans la
coiffure
je vais déjà fait la remarque mais tient
pas content oui je suis imperturbable sa
le chapeau mais pourquoi pas un chapeau
est cool mais non mais on ne critique
pas que ça lui le mieux placé pour
parler si vous gagnez 20 mille euros
voulais faire un truc que je trouve
totalement cinglé c'est ça dont je
voulais parler tout à l'heure c'était
pas la ceinture abdominale
c'était voulu faire opérer oui et ça va
changer pas votre nez et bien sonné et
puis la personne qui va vous aimez vous
aimez pour bien regarder deux profils
latéral et passant d un possible voilà
capillaire non mais non mais désagréable
tu sais oui vous avez raison et je
retourne jean-louis burgat et donc quand
tout à l'heure et disais qu'il y avait
un problème donné lui et moi tout est
venue de cette photo qui a commencé à
produire des mines est vrai année
exactement c'était l'époque où on
pouvait encore se coller c'est ça c'est
ça
mais finalement c'est pas plus mal qu'on
évite de courir à partir de maintenant
le regard des annonces de chercheurs
néo-zélandais un système anti obésité
qui permet de garder la bouche fermée
en clair vous ne pouvez plus ouvrir la
bouche donc vous ne pouvez plus manger
tu veux manger quoi
je suis pas comme ça je suis comme toi
moi ces bonbons ou des bonbons un film
de faire de sa camarade ces bateaux
allaient alors comment ça marche c'est
un système qui est installé sur vos maux
l'air un système d'aimants qui vous donc
vous bloque l'ouverture de la bouche qui
ne peut alors s'ouvrir que de 2
millimètres alors d'abord on s'est
demandé si c'était bien vrai aussi
c'était une connerie inventé sur les
réseaux sociaux à regarder ça c'est le
compte de l'université les chercheurs
néo-zélandais qui ont publié salon vous
voyez c'est un compte vérifié alors moi
on astuces beauté elle se trouve dans la
cuisine est pas dans la salle de bain
d'abord on va commencer avec le
concombre le concombre ça vous donne la
banane gaélique faut croire donc cette
astuce me vient de chez ma mère ça va
mieux gaël n'ont pas mieux
le fait est que ce dispositif n'a aucune
conséquence néfaste or pour ça ils ont
même envoyé ça peut pas parler on peut
pas parler non il doit alors pourrait
justifier sa et a expliqué hier que les
patients qui avaient testé ce système
avait perdu 6 kilos en deux semaines
un petit pas pour l'homme mais un grand
pas pour les amateurs de gras alors
cette performance cet exploit ce
tournant historique a eu lieu hier midi
en marge de l'étape du tour de france 70
kg de saucisses 500 pièces de galettes
ont permis de confectionner une galette
saucisse longue de 53 m 53 comme le
département de la mayenne qui explose
ainsi de 18 mètres le précédent record
établi dans le morbihan c'est pour
enlever les cernes ou du moins diminuer
atténuer les poches et cernes du visage
c'est m'a fait peur pour le concombre
pour un délaissé en d'accord j'ai hyper
là qu'est ce que vous vouliez qu'elle
fasse ses liens avec son concombre que
c'est parti je sors caf est un conte
contre tout l'intention du collectif
c'est pas d'être naturel et de faire ce
qu'on ce qu'on a envie de tout oser et
essaie de faire tomber un peu les
barrières et les limites et il y décède
à sion tout ça bien sûr j'étais
impatient de devenir une [ __ ] moi
même
mais d'abord je devais me plier à la
cérémonie d'initiation qui heureusement
pour moi consistait en une bonne fessée
je me suis entendu une fois pendant
trois-quatre fois quand on connaît
l'amour en fait j'étais un petit peu
trop fatigué
donc voilà mais alors dites-moi est-ce
que du coup votre chéri vous l'a dit le
lendemain matin à l'aube à huy premier
départ en près d'un mois vous a pas
réveillé pendant qu'alain on m'a dis
donc tu dors est possible de façon bio
dynamique comme je le suis
clovis en toile pour réfléchir sans
mimiques on boit un petit coup en sens
au mot d'abord que le fait d'être
d'être comique de monter sur scène et de
faire des sketches ou de raconter des
saynètes
est ce que ça vous aide aussi dans la
vente immobilière dans le sens de
l'humour et dans la détente finalement
avec laquelle vous parlez aux gens bah
effectivement moi je vous prends au mot
c'est exactement ça c'est à dire que le
jeu vos mots au no1 à guy jouer tu as
fait à chaque mot à chaque mot bien
distincts yes man mais quelle poseurs et
dans lequel peu dans une phase a eu un
effet horribles sur ma vie amoureuse mon
travail et mes amis
j'étais accro faux film dirty dancing
[Musique]
ah ouais que j'étais complètement obsédé
je pense qu'eric à dirty dancing
regardez peut-être la voiture de demain
c'est un peu comme dans le film retour
vers le futur
ça se passe en slovaquie c'est une
voiture volante elle a réussi à
parcourir 90 km dans les airs avant
d'atterrir et de poursuivre sa route
presque comme si de rien n'était en
repliant les ailes alors ça n'est pas
encore la delorean de marty mcfly
mais ça fait quand même rêver j'ai
regardé le film sept ou huit fois par
jour j'y pensais et 24 heures sur 24
enfin donc j'ai décidé de me faire
tatouer
je mentais pas quand je disais que j'ai
perdu mon travail j'ai été viré parce
que j'ai oublié d'aller travailler comme
je regardais le film ça a de la gueule
quand même à barres
et le travail réduits à néant
ça pique
imaginez vous êtes bloqués sous des
gravats
personne ne sait que vous êtes là vous
êtes coincé et bien vous allez peut-être
voir débarquer ce genre de choses c'est
à dire une armée de blattes de
madagascar sont des cafards les cafards
les plus grands qui existe c'est 7 cm
quand même de bestiaux et pour qu'on les
a choisis aussi grand et aussi gros si
l'on sait pas ce qu'on va pouvoir leur
installer un sac à dos spécial un sac à
dos avec tout un tas de capteurs des
capteurs de présence humaine un gps et
surtout ma des caméras au final je pense
oui on à rattraper tout le retard qu'on
avait et même on est peut-être à nouveau
en avance
n'oubliez pas qui a dit tony bedi
venture mais la jules césar
en somme il a quand même une bonne
culture générale parce que moi veni vidi
vici et pour moi moi c'était booba en
fait je me dis pas c'est jules césar qui
l'inventé mon frère